Hello our friends and members of the Sum
TV family. Thank you for joining us on
this edition of I'd like to know our
Bible question and answer program. I'm
surrounded by two distinguished men of
the cloth they say. Pastor Steven Boore
to my right the founder and president of
this ministry. Pastor David Salazar to
my left who is the general manager of
our Latino network and my name is CA
Murray and we are very very pleased that
you have taken a little time to join us
today for this program of ours and of
yours. Now should you want to be part of
the program and we pray that you do we
ask you to send your questions to TV at
sumsv.org.
That's tvsumtv.org
o rg and uh we will get to your
questions. Our list is rather long and
sometimes we compile the questions if we
get two or three questions dealing with
the same subject we'll compile the
questions and um sort of come out of one
uh come to one particular question by
adding the ingredients from all the
three questions. So uh remember that as
you're sending your questions in because
there are many people who have the same
issues and when we see several questions
on the same issue we compile them
together. Now today's program is just a
little bit different because we are
returning to a question that came to us
from a prior program and we didn't have
time enough to sort of exhaust it and
give the thorough answer that we wanted
to do. So we want to do that. Uh before
we begin reading the question, Pastor
Salazar, I'm going to ask you to pray
that God will be with us as we uh
wrestle with this issue.
>> Let's pray. Heavenly Father, we thank
you for once again allowing us to be
able to come to you and to be able to
open your word. We are uh so thankful
that we can spend time studying your
scriptures and realizing that you have
answers to our questions, to our
desires, and we want to honor you. We
want those who are watching to know how
to serve you better, how to love you
better, and how to understand the word
even better. So allow us to receive the
inspiration from the Holy Spirit that we
may speak and give answers that are in
harmony with your word. We thank you for
this in Jesus name.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. So I'm going to read the question
again and then um we'll sort of uh try
to deal with it as the Lord gives us the
understanding. I have been an Adventist
for a few years but sad to say I have
not been able to pay my tithe to the
Lord. I want to tithe. My husband who is
not a Christian forbids me to pay tithe.
He controls the money in our household
even though we are retired.
And each of us receives a social
security check every month. Our incomes
are combined and he pays the bills. I
have asked him numerous times and
explained the biblical reasons for
tithing and my desire to tithe. He is
adamant that we can't quote afford it.
I've been praying about it. I know the
Bible says the wife is to be submissive
to the husband in all things, but we are
also to obey God rather than man. I feel
stuck between a rock and a hard place. I
would appreciate your opinion or
insights on this issue. I feel I have
been I feel I may not be saved over this
issue. It's discouraging to me. Thank
you for your time and she prefers to
remain anonymous and we can understand
why. David, you in the last program
talked about a situation where that was
similar to this, not exactly the same,
where a woman was able to speak to her
husband and change his mind. Just
recount that quickly for us if you will.
>> Absolutely. There was an experience and
I've met a particular case where a a
wife was convicted about this particular
need and she decided to speak with her
husband time and time again reminding
him that the blessing of God was
specifically in returning to him and
that if the Lord if we if they were to
return to the tithing to the Lord they
will see the blessings they will see the
protection the even and not and she was
emphasizing so much financially gain
more, but she said, "God is going to be
with us. God is going to protect our
family. We're going to be able to have
health." And this conviction, this this
love for the Lord, uh, at first was
again rejected by the husband. But
eventually, he kind of gave in based on
her conviction. and she would be like,
"Look, I don't want, you know, I'm I'm
telling you, we need to give the tithe
to the Lord, but if you want to, you
know, go in in in flames uh by not
obeying the Lord, it's going to be on
you, not on me, because I I know what we
need to do." So, this thing came uh
after several months of of working in
his heart. He eventually gave into this
desire of hurt of returning the tithe to
the Lord. And as they did that, there
were clear evidences in their lives,
amazing miracles of God providing them
more and to bless them because of her
faithfulness. So the husband was
eventually won to the kingdom to the to
the church by seeing how the
faithfulness of tithing helped them
prevented them uh of of of getting harm
or or or they were able to see clearly
the blessings of the Lord. So in that
scenario, it was important uh for for
her to remain faithful and to sort of
emphasize the fact that God wanted her
to do that. And I wanted to add this
concept that I think is important to
remember in Ephesians 5:22 because she
mentions our friend here, the situation
that she feels that she needs to submit
to her husband in all things. But I
think it's important to remember what
exactly says in Ephesians 5:22. It says
wives submit yourselves unto your own
husbands as unto the Lord. There is an
element that she needs to submit to him
as long as he submitted and is doing in
things according to the Lord in what the
role of a man and husband should be. But
there's a limit to that. It does not
extend that submission to disobeying the
Lord or his clear word. And so I do
believe that it's important for her to
keep that in mind and to ask the Lord to
give her the strength, the kindness, and
the words to speak to her husband to
bring him to change his attitude and
hopefully win him to the kingdom.
>> Okay, that before I give it to you,
Pastor Bor, that's the the quote I have
here. Ephesians 5:22. Yeah. Um and
that's where I've underlined doesn't say
obey your husband in all things. Not in
all things. Um, sometimes you've got to
go with the Lord. And, uh, that ought to
be number one in your mind, testing and
proving the Lord. And of course, Malachi
3 says, "Prove me." Um, before I give it
to you, pastor, I had a member who came
to me with a list of her expenses
>> and also her income.
>> She said, "This is why I'm not paying
time.
>> I make this much money. I spend this
much money. Part of it is my child who
is in child care, daycare, which is
eating me alive. Uh, I cannot pay tithe.
And I said to her, you cannot afford not
to pay tithe.
>> How do you ask blessing on money that
you've taken from God when he says prove
me? He says, try me. Test me. You're not
proving him. And the reason you're
failing is because you're not proving
God. Yes.
>> Uh, now in a couple months, she actually
lost her job. And she came to me because
we had to advance her some money to get
her rent, you know, from the church the
church budget. We have a poor fund for
that. We had a poor fund for that. And
I'm saying, see, now you cannot pay your
tithe. You can't pay anything.
>> Um, so what do you do now? Now you have
to trust the Lord because you don't have
any money whatsoever.
>> Yeah.
>> In six months, she got another job.
>> Wow.
>> And it paid more than the first job. So
now she could pay her tithe. But I said,
"Had you paid your tithe when you
thought you couldn't, you would be in
better standing in the Lord." Now you
can see financially where you can, but
there's no faith now because your
balance sheet balances out.
>> Had you done it when your balance sheet
>> didn't balance out, then you would have
seen the blessings of the Lord. So I'm
glad that you have a job that pays you
enough money, but you should have paid
the tithe even when you didn't think you
had enough money to do so. I'm sorry,
Pastor
>> Bo. Yeah, it's amazing that individuals
will say u I just don't have enough
money coming in to tithe.
>> And I always say there's always a way in
which you can tithe and that is return
it first.
>> There you go.
>> Oh, but then I'm not then I won't be
able to pay all the bills. Well, um
maybe it's a good idea to be careful
with your budget and not overspend on
things that are not needed because
that's one thing that happens very
frequently. Or perhaps do what God says,
test me now.
>> Yeah.
>> Tithe first, return what belongs to me
first. And God always with a request,
always makes a promise.
>> Yes.
>> He says, I will open the windows of
heaven. I will pour out a blessing till
you don't have room to receive it. Mhm.
>> The question is, will we test the Lord
and be obedient to the Lord and leave
the consequences with him?
>> Um, you know, it's difficult to do it
sometimes. It reminds me of the widow,
uh, you know, that, uh, Elijah met me.
>> Yeah.
>> Um,
you know, Elijah comes and he says to
her, you know, make me a little, she's
using the last oil and the last flour.
>> Yes.
>> To prepare the last meal. And here this
selfish prophet says, you know, but
that's fine. Do it, but make me a little
loaf first.
>> First.
>> Yeah, he does say that.
>> No. Yeah.
>> Now, if if for some reason she had said,
>> let's die with a full stomach,
>> then uh God would not have kept his
promise.
>> But God promised the oil is not going to
lacking. The flower is not going to
lacking until it rains on the earth
again.
>> Yes.
>> She had to make a decision. Do I do what
I'm supposed to do or not?
>> She chose
>> to be faithful.
>> Yes.
>> And the oil and the flour did not run
out until it rained on the earth.
>> Amen.
>> So, um God asks us to test him. And it's
interesting here that this this uh uh
person uh repeated says I've t I've
talked to him numerous times
>> and uh you know it's fallen on deaf
ears. Um actually the her question also
clearly says that uh the social security
uh both of them receive social security.
>> Mhm. So technically speaking, her social
security is hers,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> Her social security is hers. It's not
his.
>> Uh so um how can he dictate
uh her not tithing from social security
that comes from the social uh security
administration to her? Um it's a
difficult situation
but uh you know being faithful to God
never fails.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. You know I'm I'm thinking this
gentleman and and we have not discussed
this matter per se. Um
you touched on something Pastor Boore.
She gets social security. He gets social
security. We don't want to say anything
that would cause World War II to break
out in his home. Of course not.
>> But I would also say my mind says pay
tithe on the money that you control.
>> You know, you can't you can't
take his check or any part of his check.
It looks like the money goes into a
common account,
>> but perhaps she's getting money for
groceries. She's getting money for other
things. He may be giving her an
allowance.
>> Pay tithe on that allowance. Start
there.
>> Yeah.
>> And then build from there. But the money
that's under your direct control, pay
tithe on that. You you follow where I'm
going with this?
>> If if uh she is receiving some kind of
funding that she can administrate
herself
>> precisely because he may be taking it
all. We don't we don't know and we don't
want to step into that. But if she's
getting money that she has control over,
pay tithe on what you control,
>> right?
>> Uh and then watch the Lord bless
as you do a little bit for him as you
understand it. We we know that this obey
your husband in all things is not
biblical. So do what you can. Uh the
Bible says this ought you should have
done and not to do the other undone. So
paying tithe is not tithe is not an
optional thing. It's something God
>> needs to have us to do.
>> Yeah.
>> When we and and how can you ask God's
blessing on your life when you're
stealing from him? And that's what this
is. That's what that whole Malachi thing
is about. Stealing from God. You want
God's best, you must give him your best.
So start with my dear sister the money
that you control and then sit back and
and watch God work for you with you and
through you to do to do best.
>> And the bottom line is that God is going
to hold him accountable.
>> Yes.
>> He's not you know if she has no control
whatsoever
over the money say that the money is
deposited directly in the bank and he
has control over all the money. Uh I
don't think that she is accountable
because he's the one that's controlling
the money.
>> Agreed.
>> And so uh you know God is going to hold
him accountable. He's not going to hold
her accountable
>> for what she has no control.
>> Absolutely. And and she can use the
principle of
the consistent persistent widow that we
find in the Bible. You know just speak
to his heart. Talk to him consistently.
say I don't want to rob the Lord. Remind
him what the word of God talks about.
You know, will go will men rob God? Uh
emphasize the fact that it is a act of
worship that returning to the Lord what
he says is his. It's not theirs. And and
I know that it's it's it's hard
sometimes because some people, you know,
might not want to hear that or or or but
I think that as she speaks to his heart
and ask the Lord for guidance, she might
find a way to to pers persuade him to
change his position of being so sting,
you know, stingy, I guess, or so
covetousness or have such a covet for
the money and return to the Lord and let
her tell him to prove the Lord, to test
the Lord. the Lord gives a blessing, a
promise for those who return that which
belongs to him. So I think that she
needs to have uh the assurance that if
she submits to the Lord and ask the Lord
for wisdom and she's persistent,
there's probably a very good outcome or
chance that the Lord will work in his
heart to to to to make him change. And
if he's not, like you said, pastor, then
she's out of, you know, I don't think
she's liable for not being able to do
what she needs to do. Even the unjust
judge
>> did justice to the widow to get her off
his back.
>> I got tired of hearing it. That's what
I'm saying.
>> We We would hope that that would not be
his motivation.
>> Yeah. Right. Right.
>> You know, she's comes and comes and
said, "We need to tithe. We need to
tithe." And well, you know, let's tithe
because I'm tired to hear about it. I
I'm hoping that uh it would be like God
in the story of the judge where God
where God delays right for our good but
then he says I'm going to do justice
because I love her.
>> Exactly.
>> And so hopefully that would be the
attitude. Let's hope that's the case.
>> Pastor, would you offer a quick word of
prayer? I'm just very burdened for this
particular uh sister in Christ and um
let's just lift her up quickly in
prayer.
>> Father in heaven, we come before your
awesome throne. We come in the powerful
name of Jesus.
>> Amen. In this life, we have many
situations where uh decisions are very
difficult and this is one of those
cases. Uh I ask Lord that you will come
close to this sister. Uh help her not to
feel guilty about this because her heart
is right. She believes that she should
tithe and if she had control, she would
tithe. I just ask Lord that you will
give her your peace. you will give her
your comfort that uh you will work upon
her husband's heart that he might
understand the importance of tithing and
what a blessing it will be. So I ask
that you'll be with her. Give your give
her your peace. Work upon his heart and
I ask that this whole situation might be
resolved for your honor and your glory.
We pray in Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen. And amen. All right. Um we've got
a little time left. Um Todd from Kfax,
California writes us. He's dealing with
Revelation 17:10. Pastor Dave, if you
can get that for us quickly. Yes.
>> I do not understand how John is viewing
this after the fifth head has fallen.
According to you, the fifth head is
papal Rome and John's vision was before
this. Please explain.
>> Okay, I read Revelation 17:10. It says
there are also seven kings. Five have
fallen, one is, and the other has not
yet come. And when he comes, he must
continue a short time.
>> Okay. Th this question uh basically is
directed to yours truly.
>> Yes, indeed.
>> Because um you know, I I participated at
Andrews University uh recently in a
Revelation 17 symposium.
uh it was a real blessing. There were
lay people that presented papers. I had
the privilege of presenting papers.
There were scholars there also from
Andrews and from Melinda that presented.
And um basically the answer to this
question is not complicated. Mhm.
>> Uh verses 1 and two uh tell us, "Then
one of the seven angels who had the
seven bowls came and talked with me,
saying to me, "Come, I will show you the
judgment of the great harlot who sits on
many waters."
>> Yeah.
>> Uh this is actually taking John to the
future
>> to the time when the papacy recovers
from its deadly wound.
>> True.
>> Absolutely. and the waters that it
controls which are multitudes, nations,
tongues and peoples are once again
supporting the harlot.
>> Yes.
>> So basically John is being transported
>> to to the end time.
>> But but uh it would do no good just to
transform transport him to the end time
without giving a frame of reference.
>> Yes. EV without rooting him where the
harlot lived before and eventually leads
to the recover recovery from her wound
and the flowing of the waters again at
the end.
>> Exactly.
>> So, so what John does is uh it begins by
taking him to the end time when the
harlot's wound is healed. She's
controlling the multitudes and the
nations and tongues. And by the way, at
the end they turn against her in
Revelation 17. What a triumph. And then
he's taken back to uh the five that are
fallen. Babylon, Meo, Persia, Greece,
Rome, papal Rome that received the
deadly wound
>> and then takes him to the end time. Uh
and so we need to understand that
Revelation is not in chronological
order.
>> It goes back and forwards. It goes in
cycles. It takes you to the end, then it
takes you to the beginning. And the key
to understanding the book is how the
book is structured. So, so the answer to
this question simply is that uh John is
taken to the end time and then uh the
angel takes him back for a frame of
reference takes him back to middle
Persia, Greece, uh Babylon, middle
Persia, Greece, Rome, etc. And then
moves in all the way to the end again in
this chapter.
>> Very good. Very good. Very very well
said. I I wrote a note here that it's
it's the on-ramp to sitting on many
waters. How did you get there? Well,
>> right.
>> That's we're there.
>> This is how we got there. Yeah.
>> Uh so it it gives you uh context for for
for both. Pastor, did you have anything
else?
>> Well, no. Just agreeing with pastor bore
that it's important to remember that
this particular chapter chapter 17 it's
again speaking of that woman that harlot
who is who has gained or regained the
supremacy on the world and this is where
the nations and the people are all
praising and and looking up to her. So
like you said, it's really understanding
where the where this is taking place to
see why the Lord showed him and made him
understand five have fallen and where
he's looking into right now. So it it
really solves the question easily for
that particular question. But this
chapter it's so important and as you
said pastor you had this this study this
symposium that you made. I I I encourage
our viewer Todd to look into those
materials that are available now and
then you can be able to see clearly more
this chapter.
>> It was last year's anchor school of
theology.
>> Uh it took 24 hours to really fully
understand Revelation 17.
>> Yeah.
>> Um and uh the the study notes are
available. It's called Prophecies
Repeating Sequence.
>> And the key is to begin with Daniel 2.
Daniel 7 expands on Daniel 2. Mhm.
>> Revelation 12 expands upon Daniel 2 and
Daniel 7. Revelation 13 expands upon
Daniel 2, Daniel 7, and Revelation 12.
>> Mhm.
>> Revelation 13 expands upon Revelation 12
and Daniel 7 and Daniel 2. The last and
greatest expansion is Revelation 17.
>> Correct.
>> And only as you see that building
pattern
>> will you be able to understand
Revelation 17.
>> And you have no doubt. uh there was
actually a scholar that that presented
and uh you know I presented my paper and
then afterwards there was an opportunity
for questions and uh the scholar said
you know I'd never thought about that
layered approach uh to you know to the
book of revelation and its relationship
with Daniel. Um see the the thing is
Revelation 17 speaks about the harlot
sitting on many waters.
>> But that harlot has persecuted in the
past represents the papacy. Yes.
>> So in Revelation 12, you have this
dragon that's spewing water out of his
mouth.
>> To persecute just like the harlot in
Revelation 17,
>> uh the dragon is spewing out waters upon
which he sits.
>> Mhm.
>> So So there you see that you have to
start
>> exactly
>> with Revelation 12.
>> Uh the waters flowing, persecuting God's
people for time, times the dividing of
time. That's past. And that is the
foundation of the basis for the flowing
of the waters again in the future. So,
um, the structure, uh, how it is
organized is of crucial importance.
>> Yeah. Well said. And that's why I said
it's the on-ramp. If you want to get on
a freeway, you just don't jump on a
freeway. You got to get on that side
road and get up to speed, then you get
on the freeway. So, you're getting up to
speed is in Daniel, Daniel, Daniel, then
Revelation uh uh 12 and 13, then you're
kind of up to speed for for 17. But if
you just try to jump on the 17, it
doesn't make a lot of sense and it is
confusing.
>> Absolutely. Yeah.
>> And I think that you know as you said I
encourage our our viewers to get that
material pastor board that you have made
available your uh anchor school of
theology that that class is super
important and I think those who love the
scriptures and prophecy will really
benefit from that particular study.
>> In our few closing seconds I want to put
in a commercial for anchor school of
theology. It's not just uh a series of
meetings. This is practical material
that you can use to strengthen your walk
with the Lord. That's what it was
designed for. Uh, so get the study notes
if you can't come in person. Again, our
time has slipped away from us. We'll see
you again soon. Bye-bye and God bless.